tout cas dans leur match contre contre
du coup je suis pas dans le bon chat
contre l'iran je vous laisse arrivée
dans le chat du support encore je vais
cesser et rim qui n'était pas vraiment
prévu à fond de base mais à
mais bon voilà on avait envie de faire
plaisir aux gens qui organisent ça
qu'ils sont assez sympa c'est donc j'ai
un peu discuté avec chaises comme
j'aurais dit oui ce serait cool à te
faire des petits stream histoire que les
gens soient soient au courant de base là
on n'a pas vraiment on va on va on va se
faire manger ce soir mais mais on va
dire on dit qu'on joue le long terme
quoi on dit qu'on joue le long terme et
qu'on va pouvoir qu'on va pouvoir faire
mieux par la suite
donc je vais à je vois juste je dois
juste mettre un truc en ligne et je suis
avec vous safer keller alors à mettre 15
allez je suis quasiment avec vous jouez
à remplir non je me suis je me suis
planté je me suis planté évidemment je
vais essayer de chat sur le téléphone
c'est pas idiot
psa doit sur le téléphone parce que je
me suis trompé dans l'eure mais ça va ça
va être rapide a changé hop et
maintenant il reste plus qu'à voir le
bon chat et je vais être avec vous je
passais déjà des gens arrivent et allez
ça arrive tout doucement bon c'est
contre l'iran cyril ouais c'est ça
exactement
exactement et si vous voulez participer
vous avez toutes les infos
ici je vais vous n'êtes dans le chat non
pour participer à la team france assez
simple il suffit sellami père simple il
suffit juste pas de cliquer vous y
participer immédiatement ça commence à
19h30 donc comme ça je concédais un peu
en avance pour avoir le temps comme ça
vous avez vous avez un peu de la lepreau
le premier sert un + 1 après le joue en
5 + 2 je crois après on joue en dise
plus quelque chose je sais pas si adrian
cham qui s'occupe de l'équipe qui est là
perso je connais pas exactement le
déroulement de la compétition mais voilà
ça va permettre de faire des petits
stream ii de faire découvrir
moi je veux pas spécialement essayer de
bien jouer ni rien je vais je vais le
faire sans prétention à la rage j'ai
envie de dire on verra on verra ce que
ça donne j'ai mis je remets le lien dans
le chat pour les gens qui trouvent pas
dans les deux et merci à l'école
d'honneur aph pour le twitch prime merci
tonton l'histoire de la tête au rapido
est déjà le 5 + 2 tu peux tu peux le
faire ça y est le meilleur nom déjà déjà
tu peux tu peux tu peux le réaliser à
genre il faut il faut qu'ils acceptent
la demande d'inscription puis pas s'ils
sont sur le coup salut stasiak
ils sont censés être sur le coup ils
sont censés être sur le coup ça lui
sourit coco l'asticot bon donc on se
fait ce petit délire là c'est pas envie
de dire c'est un stream un peu
supplémentaires moi j'étais en train de
faire du tfc avant j'ai envie de dire
mais juge m'étais mis d'accord avec sam
qui bossent pour czech comme j'ai dit
ouais la team france on a quand même
envie de leur file un coup de main et
donc je leur ferai un petit stream et
voilà de temps en temps les dimanches
quand je suis chez moi tranquille ou
pépère on se fera des petits stream pour
essayer de gagner des matchs et de et
d'avoir de plus en plus de gens il ya
déjà des gens là dans le chat qui ont
qui ont déjà joué c'est qu'on pète ou
s'est jamais arriver un joueur fort joue
avec la team france voilà pour moi on
n'a pas de fort 1 n'a pas de fort mais
bon ça ça permette de 6,6 si je fais des
stream à chaque fois environ va
renforcer l'équipe 1 les mecs ça va
renforcer ils ont des mecs fort devant
ils ont une équipe assez forte 1
franchement franchement ils sont plus
forts que nous mais j'en arrivais bah
écoute toi et c'est eux
tu peux tu peux suivre le lien on va
faire un petit match contre l'iran je
devrais peut-être en vrai crime cap sur
le truc en vrai je vais escrime tape sur
le truc pour que les gens comprennent
puisque c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est
pas forcément hyper intuitif on va voir
ce que ça donne
en gros voilà le match quoi voilà voilà
les buy par les beaux et on n'est pas
très beau là dans le match donc il faut
les suivre
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la team
france puis après trouver dans l'est
dans les tournois le match entre le club
français le club et le club dire en quoi
c'est pas forcément super simple la
première fois mais une fois que vous
l'avez fait une fois c'est un prêt c'est
automatique
ce serait cool qu'on a un peu des gens
qui se ramène à bron mise peut-être pas
tout sur le bullet 1 ont misé peut-être
pas tout sur le bullet ont misé
peut-être aussi sur sur les cadences
plus longues on va voir on va voir on va
voir à la janis joplin merci pour ton
coup de pouce je suis là pour valider
les demandes vas-y vas-y adrian on va
essayer de va essayer de faire quelques
stream l' histoire de tu vois histoire
de bien faire mal à toutes les équipes
adverses là on a on a décidé que ça
pouvait plus faire là c'est plus
possible c'est plus possible
on joue toujours le maintien j'ai
l'impression dans cette ligue tu te lis
toujours en sueur à jouer le maintien ou
je sais pas trop où on va on va on va on
va on va s'occuper de ça on va essayer
d'aller jouer la gagne j'ai neuf cent
cinquante lots je peux participer ouais
bien sûr bien sûr maximum de gens qui
participent
ça ne peut être que positif donc
participé à fond déjà on va essayer de
gagner le combat du nombre et après on
gagnera le combat de la force si on le
fait souvent c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir
du monde
pakito qui dit qu'il n'est pas dans la
liste
cité dans la liste qu'est-ce qui me dit
paquito paquito en sueur face face aux
webmasters duchess comme paquito fillon
sur face à face à la technologie de
chasse comme technologie très avancée
qui fait mal pour s'inscrire il faut
suivre
il faut suivre les deux liens dans un
premier temps
vous avez liens de la team france et
dans un deuxième temps on va on va
chercher le titre les amis donc on
commence par du bullet si j'ai bien
compris après c'est du 5 plus quelque
chose et après alors à temps des
premiers essais du coi 19h50 1 + 1 après
c'est du 5 + 2 après c'est du 10 + 2
donc 19h30 19h50 20h30
enfin je veux rajouter ça aussi c'est
quoi je vais faire une petite capture
d'écran c'est une capture d'écran pas
piquée des hannetons
et on va on va aller chercher à moi je
vais je vais vous m je vais le mettre à
jouer le maître sur l'échiquier au moins
on voit bien et puis on enlèvera ouais
c'est du bullet en plus un c'est un
peuple autres j'en ai jamais joué
quasiment donc on va voir on va voir ce
que ça donne puisque l'équipe se
renforce
ça renforce pas trop les mecs pour le
bon ça renforce pas trop en faire le taf
1 les personnes qui s'inscrit bon on
commence à être plus nombreux que quand
même ça cesse mais bon après ce que ça
sert vraiment à quelque chose chez pas
mais peut-être on peut aller les taper
là les résas rahmani lââm c'est faux à
l'épaule et une tapée l'arrière-garde la
côte est je vais les mettre en plus
grand même on va on va on va leur mettre
là on va mettre leur équipe
je sais pas comment on peut s'organiser
elle serait bien qu'on met ça en plus
grand bassam est un conte l'étape
derrière là qu'on s'est inscrit à fond
derrière et qu'on aille à et qu'on a il
est tapé là bas on va se mettre comme ça
et on va mettre les équipes ça c'est le
premier match
ouais non la forêt du monde qui vit en
bullet là on peut peut-être ça peut
peut-être se joue à pas grand chose
derrière monsieur luca monsieur luca il
peut il peut faire le taf excès de sébum
aussi il ya du bon on dirait le frigo
bruiteur ya du bon dans cette équipe ah
c'est une grosse équipe qu'on a là un je
vois pas comment ils peuvent nous
résister on a on a un gros milieu de
tableau c'est devant qu'on va souffrir
devant on va souffrir parce que lui il
m'a l'air pas mal mais rapide lui 2800
bullet c'est un peu chaud moi je fais
plus de bulles est en plus progression
brian flrl ah là là on va on va avoir
mal la devance honnêtement les gars
ça fait assez mal sur les 15 premiers
échiquiers et c'est que à partir de
ouais c'est à partir de là il ya plus de
200 points d'écart 100 points d'écart on
peut faire le taf afin que vous phare
que vous donniez tout ce que vous avez
là les mecs sains va falloir assez
collectif
c'est collectif
buzz pour qu'on gagne c'est parce qu'ils
nous manquent pour qu'on gagne les mecs
mais à l'affût à faire de copier coller
escadrille anshan a encore le lien
bonjour mes liens
pour rejoindre pour rejoindre la team
france et après aller à aller dans
tournoi sur czech comme live comme tout
comme toujours c'est à la demande et à
s'inscrire il n'est pas venu s'inscrire
au match om il va peut-être venir la
crypte talent france fait quand même à
prague dont ils ont eu beau monde en dit
long du beau monde
ça se voit que la compétition leur leur
tient à coeur côté iranien
c'est pas sympa prénom c'est vrai qu'il
te mettent ils te mettent cinq titres et
devant quoi ils te mettent des bons
devant et mais même après ça fait mal et
non ils sont ils sont vraiment est-ce
que heskey adriaenssens a fait partie
des grosses équipes ça un autre
adversaire à peu près de notre niveau
c'est fou le random pour lé match making
non c'est pas fou le random si tu joues
le la même tête de série côté adverse
on peut rejoindre plus tard ou sera trop
tard
il y aura deux ya trois matches en fait
t'as les horaires juste en dessous 19h30
19h50 20h30 du coup tu peux tu peux
choisir le match qui te qu'il convient
mois le disent + 2 je suis pas sûr que
le jour est perso mais n'hésitez pas
on est on est dans le dur j'aurais
peut-être dû commencer contre
l'argentine comme les stream sur ceux
sur cet event juste 300 400 points
l'autre différence à être un massacre à
léon par pas défaitiste là les mecs un
allez on se parent je veux pas je veux
pas avoir de défaitisme là dans le chat
un aléa on se bat on donne tout un mois
si vous faites les vous heures je vous
parle match regarde moi j'ai deux cent
cinquante points et l'autre moins que le
gars je vais je vais je vais tout donner
je vais aller le chercher un
on va pas on va pas on va pas commencer
à pleurer et si on y va comme ça on va
on va prendre on va prendre 60 0 la
halle et ça ça se fait 1 200 points
d'écart en bullet syrien a surtout à
petit niveau
moi je dis vous pouvez vous pouvez le
faire après c'est vrai qu'ils sont quand
même très nombreux mais mais vous pouvez
quand même aller aller chercher des perf
là les iraniens sont d'habitude
légèrement devant nous et ben je sais
pas ce qu'ils ont fait pour ce match là
il ya le coronavirus chez eux je sais
pas quoi ils sont enfermés chez eux ils
ont décidé de nous mettre 50 0 la
spectateurs occasionnels non mais à un
moment faut arrêter kevin ces morts pour
la france
non mais arrête arrêtez les gars enfin
vous n'avez jamais fait de compet c'est
quoi le sait quoi le délire c'est quoi
le délire les mecs ça s'est jamais joué
en compétition avec une équipe des mecs
à côté ils me disent c'est perdu
d'avancé temps mais c'est jamais perdu
un cas une des conseils pour le bullet
pour les bouffées jouer vite et bien
amal et faut aller à faut se battre le n
10 je peux bien ces rois et tout le
monde peut s'inscrire là on a besoin on
a besoin de tout le monde là vous jouez
dit eh bien tout le monde joue vite et
bien dans ce match aller on va aller
chercher les mailles calais
là en l'occurrence à en perdre une
avance banon moi je te dis faut moi je
suis dit il faut y aller maintenant il
ya monsieur patate qui est là d'habitude
ils jouent avec les tchèques bram il
nous a rejoint pour ce match
attention monsieur patate et là il a la
patate elle serait bien d'avoir ce genre
petite dizaine de joueurs forts en plus
on a un peu léger quand même mais bon
derrière je me dis non mais derrière 15
50 17 77 ou franchement vous pouvez le
faire les mains car j'ai confiance 1 g
super confiance en cassel rouge par
exemple castel rouge jeu tant qu'il est
là pour prendre le point lui gaspille
beau il est là aussi
et regardez on est plus nombreux on est
beaucoup plus nombreux que dj grotte
drop à mon avis c'est un bon gars noces
est un bon le frigo bruiteur c'est un
bon romain ménard j'ai envie de te dire
c'est ça va être ça va être une
boucherie gaz mais bon il va falloir
qu'ils montrent un peu tout ce qu'il a
pris dans les stream pédagogique ils
essuient souvent pareil pour jeff 85
il ya cristal qui est là et adrian
chamia jacquot tempo j'arrive quand même
du monde
il ya quand même du monde côté français
il ya gaspille boy il ya 110 des soirs
tu vois j'ai envie de te dire c'est une
équipe c'est la dream team la côté
français les amis il ya une phase
horonya paquito il ya guillaume mérie qu
il a golden france 123 yahia baptiste
avec 2,21 y ont saisi sait pas écrire
mais il est quand même là il ya cryptage
les mecs à cri talent on a crypte à la
fin j'ai envie de dire c'est une équipe
de chacun va falloir que les iraniens
ils viennent nous chercher là il ya le
fasse d'euros dans l'équipe on est bon
les mecs
ouais mais ces patates crypte aller tout
ça ça commence à bégayer côté iranien là
ça commence à bégayer
pour s'inscrire car il faut il faut il
faut s inscrire à la team france d'abord
et après tu peux t'inscrire est une
lutte pour ce match façon il ya trois
matches allez les mecs
moi je vais aller je vais aller le
chercher
je vais aller le chercher les mecs ya
pas de raison il n'y a pas de raison je
vais enlever un jeu enlevé le truc
après ce match je pense qu'il va y va
dire ça le mec des milliers d'euros en
faisant du coup il va faire bûcheron la
roméo mais moon vient d'un quart la team
france c'est ou à précédents échecs live
comme si tu allais jouer sur thiès comme
en direct tu vas dans l'onglet tournois
en haut à droite et c'est le premier
match il y aura deux matches qui
suivront la il reste 30 secondes ça va
démarrer mais si vous ratez celui-là de
façon prochain match à 19 50
allez les amis on y va allez moi je vais
le taper au mas homayoun homayoun to
file ait déjà avec le pseudo ils font
perdre du temps il en mauvaise internet
voilà fischer s'est voilà c'est bien
assez bien dit ça allez on va gagner sur
sur la connexion internet
non mais regardez ya des gens ils
peuvent même pas jouer tellement nahd
nombre on est on est on est super
nombreux les mecs qui peut s'asseoir à
notre table et dire il ya plus de
joueurs que nous allez on y va
allez c'est parti bonne chance à tous
pas si je vais faire des quatre jours
une française contre un français c'est
quoi c'est quoi le sait quoi le bail
vas-y moi j'ai fait la master class avec
fable guide
je suis très confiant vas-y bouffe le
pion
je vais toujours tempo 7 ou trois je met
le four en c2 chercher du v4 tête le
chasser je me place ok j'arrête le
cavaly si je met le fou en d4
je vais chercher du cavalier e 5
je vais tout péter je vais tout claquer
les magal et je claque
le joueur français qui envoie un échec
deux échecs ok tranquille dans un show 4
un petit coup de pouce et 5 je suis pas
sûr de fou c'est 5 à 4 j'aime pas
j'allais chercher tour f3
cela n'est pas question
c'est chaud il veut mater
c'était pas très bien joué je vais aller
mater aussi il n'empêche il m'a mystifié
et je me suis foutu ma l'otan
je vais rater
je pensais pas qu'il allait qu'il allait
prendre là nul désolé les mecs
désolé l'élite je pensais pas qu'il
allait pleutre bâgé santé je voyais plus
courageux de ça les iraniens
j'ai pas réussi à finir le couple ainsi
si je suis un peu déçu mais bon
apprendre ici faire des six mais là je
suis mal qu'à la rigueur je vais laisser
prendre le faire plonger élite
je suis pas super confiant âgées parfois
je dois la fin c'est moi
alaya cavalière 6 way où ça j'ai pas à
9,4 et jaka valls 5
c'est un problème
ça c'est vers le jeu via l'émission
prend aux qu'elle a oublié aussi une
problème c'est que c'est quoi le
problème
pas si clair le joueur français quand il
est là deux joueurs français il
s'arrache et les amis au les amis os et
gagner c'est gagner les amis je vous ai
dit qu'il fallait se battre j'en ai dit
qu'il fallait se battre dans ce match
mais l'équipe française qui mène au
score les amis les français qui mène les
français qui mène 48 à 48 à 42
on est là les amis 49 à 42 c qui dans le
chat qui a dit qu'on allait perdre
avance c'est qui qui a écrit ça dans le
chat les amis on est en train de gagner
les amis on est en train de le gagner ce
match et c'est qui qui avait perdu
d'avancé
c'était se perdant il n'a pas joué il a
pas gagné avec nous hyper aussi aller
les amis 56 à 43 c'est un massacre les
amis c'est un massacre
on est là on est là on les massacre on
est on est en train de on est en train
de on est en train de leur faire très
très mal là aux iraniens environ sur les
amis d'hier on sûr c'est bien jouer les
mecs 59 59 48 59 60 49 ans mon avis a
presque tout y est déjà finie il ya plus
de 10 points d'écart on peut veut on
peut on peut essayer de suivre une
partie ses patates qui est dans le dur
franchement si on va chercher la gagne
ici à [ __ ] en d2 monsieur patate
non oui le voit il le voit aller c'est
important le match est serré il faut
décès de feu trois échecs savary vous
allez monsieur patate
monsieur patate à la tâte pas ces trois
je sais pas si ça marche on sait rien
c'était très bien jouer ce coup non ils
menacent maths en un an le joueur
iranien qui va l'emporter
ouais c'est bien joué côté iranien via
ça va ça va revenir au score 65 65 les
amis 66 partout non non c'est la
dernière game je crois le français qui
est mal bah il a gardé des amis il a
gagné non 67 67 non non non il ya une
égalisation de la papauté
non le joueur français qui est perdante
va perdre on va perdre les amis on va
perdre on va perdre ce match prenons 68
quelle horreur je suis écoeuré les amis
je suis écoeuré on avait 40 points
d'avance là
raji cru les à nice
j'ai cru les amis on était bien dans ce
match on se fait remonter soit 109 assez
décevant spectateurs ou kg d'ail vient
faire le malin en k&n j'attendais un
score de 20 points on n'était pas loin
de gagner ce match on avait 14 points
d'avance on a craqué les amis on s'est
bien battu les mets bravo à vous
très tôt en g3
3 2 ouais ça à perdre sa perte de 4
points
vous êtes bien battu l'aînée quand même
vous êtes bien battus quand même bravo à
vous on perd que 2 4 points contre
contre une équipe beaucoup plus forte
que la nôtre
allez on joue le jeu vous le deuxième
match dans neuf minutes on n'a perdu que
de quatre points ça je vous commencez
c'est l'accumulation des points c'est
quoi c'est quoi le goal avérage adrian
cham c'est quoi le départage on s'est
bien battu on s'est bien battu sérieux
c'était c'était beau les français les
français qui ont tout donné
les français ont tout donné a laissé
couler said on essaye de se battre sur
la prochaine de nouveau aller on donne
tout
tous les mecs mardan huit minutes
il ya une grosse équipe en face sont
plus forts que nous attend mais que
c'est bon quand même
c'est une exigence pas le temps pour les
prochaines désolé rei ce paragraphe
frais wei wei ça va on a tout donné les
mecs on a tout donné mais ça c'était
c'était correct
cette niche deuxième match quand on fait
par l'aval des mots durs je crois qui
clôt donne automatiquement un buteur
comme ça ils vont avoir le droit à l
appel de la part du président al gore si
j'avais pas changé le truc c'est le
socle sur ma chaîne perso bah du coup
merci à
je veux dire merci je vois je vois je
vais voir le blast dugast et chari qui a
pris à un tweet qui prime sur ma chaîne
perd ce qu'il a dit d aller de loose à
cause de moi en premier bizarre que je
suis déjà en pls autant en 10 0 as pas
grave sérieux c'est faisable on peut on
peut on peut le faire sur ce deuxième
match
moi les mecs j'y crois l'important c'est
qu'on y croit tous
si on y croit actions si on y croit tous
on peut retourner des montagnes les amis
on peut retourner des montagnes c'était
avant tu prends une montagne que la
retourne on peut le faire les mecs
sérieux on peut le faire on est français
quand même bordel a pareillement sont
beaucoup plus équilibré ouais mais ça va
être chaud le premier match franchement
il y en a peut-être qui n'ont pas assumé
qui n'ont pas assumé la différence et
l'eau et qui ont peu fait dans leurs
cales sont en jeu j'ai envie de dire
j'accuse personnes mai mais un peu quand
même
j'ai pas je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
il ya il ya quelque chose qui a mal
tourné les mecs je crois qu'il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas assumé leurs lots je
dis ça je dis rien des gens qui n'ont
pas assumé qui n'ont pas assumé les
différences et l'eau allait on s'inscrit
là un fort et qu'on retrouve fricktal
fois les cours trouvent
voilà on a peine à trouver de ping-pong
ou là qui vient qui vient renforcer
allez on n'a pas peur les mecs
j'en ai beaucoup plus nombreux que quoi
ça ça devrait donner des points bonus je
suis désolé ça devrait donner du bonus
un ca devrait pas jouer en face à ces en
train de dans le dans le chat de
discussions c'est en train de parler
iranien là c'est en train de parler
farsi ça parle farsi
on va les farcir un ouais en fait ils
ont il faut une stratégie font pas jouer
les petites et l'eau c'est quoi c'est
quoi le délire là c'est ça fera demande
à le changer à de garrincha main dans
cette compétition si ça fait fort fait
un temps dit
revoir en plus exactement c'est tout on
est beaucoup plus nombreux on nous donne
des points
ce pas normal d'un mois j'ai eu beaucoup
de réussite gamin appartient donc à nos
sympathies à 1836 et pourtant c'est un
nom sur trois corps et à cris talia poum
poum poum
il ya du monde allez faut aller les
chercher les mac 1 franchement ils sont
prenables
franchement ils sont prenables mais on
est tellement plus quoi cessession quand
même de laisser comme ça non mais là il
y aurait 30 points à prendre facilement
serait pas normal
allez c'est biaisé puisque du coup ça
viage le truc s'agir pourquoi est ce
qu'à un poids thorel avantage devant
avec 2004 contre 2200 et nous on
n'aurait pas davantage avec six ans ou
alors il jouerait contre stoke liche
niveau 1 ou un truc comme ça
ah mais on mérite juste on mairie bordel
on mérite largement en fait
c'est normal c'est juste normal en fait
c'est victoire par forfait ce serait
presque ok ils reviennent avec des gm
devant ils s'appellent entre eux mais
derrière il y a personne tu vois ça
c'est ça j'aime pas ça pour moi les
échecs c'est un esprit j'aime j'aime pas
j'aime pas cet esprit tu voit entre
entre pro tu as on est entre nous tu
vois ce que je veux dire jorion gagne le
match entre nous tout j'aime pas j'aime
pas trop cet esprit là je préfère
l'esprit sympa tu as essayé de faire
participer tout le monde joue ensemble
on se fait kiffer j'aime pas trop ce
délire tu vois on ramène des potes
grands maîtres on gagne le truc away
mais ça sert à rien en fait un tt entre
car vous êtes entre vous vous êtes
quatre gars et demie quoi j'aime pas
trop cet esprit là
pressez chacun chacun ses goûts chacun
son délire mais à mes s'effacer pas bon
délire à moi en tout cas c'est bien un
genre amateurs et tous ces coups là au
contraire au contraire
mais on changeait niava wave germes ans
n'a pas de budget un spectateur
occasionnel tu vas pas les faire jouer
un mois par l'approché slicks que c'est
un truc un peu médiatique et que c'est
sympa mais là pour un truc comme ça
c'est compliqué aucun titre et rejouer
moi moi je suis là couailhac [ __ ] il
n'est pas titré mais il est là aussi
quoi on se bat avec nos armes non mais
franchement c'est rien des grands
maîtres là faut pas que vous serez siens
vous avez vu le nombre de gens que j'ai
battu de grands maîtres faux-pas faut
pas paniquer 1
c'est pas parce qu'il ya deux lettres
devant son nom que ça encaissa ça fait
ça en fait quelqu'un de fois s'il était
si fort que ça
ce qui est champion du monde franchement
on peut on peut se battre
ben moi je compte heureusement mais bon
une nouvelle fois autant ils ont les
grands maîtres pour eux bon bravo à
bravo à eux c'est bien mais nous là il
ya il ya 2 4 6 8
il ya il ya une vingtaine de points à
prendre là et voilà je vous c'est un
petit peu dommage je me répète mais bon
derrière on est favoris quand même hein
donc vous seriez vous seriez les fesses
derrière va falloir serrer les fêtes les
laisse enfin derrière va pas falloir me
dire
tonton kev surtout il aime ça surtout
lmsa et mer se fait le plus pour qu'aux
merci pour le set sur maps sur ma chaîne
perso au passage va pas falloir venir me
dire tonton kiev j'ai raté ma game un
film joueurs mais je vous ce truc
pleutres
une cata se sent le foot pas grave
4 j'ai cette petite finale écoute on va
jouer tu veux jouer la finale on va la
jouer je pense je peux prendre ferké et
17 b45 le fou appartient plutôt à cette
diagonale je pense ici pour faire 3 et
peut-être g3 c'est une perte de temps
même quand il fait payer 5 qui on prend
fois si j'aurai des tours b 8 qui
viendront défendre je pense ça va 5
plutôt si notre cadence 1 c'est moins ce
que j'ai l'habitude de jouer mais à
kayes qui est pk13 je me injectés idc
jamais un jeu pour le pion à 1,5 à bobby
fischer pour le point 5 donc été hissé
cas s'il veut 4 qui peut être pénible
ipod touch noël qui vont aujourd'hui
enlève cette fève 5 x 5
il va peut-être h3 à ce moment là moi
j'ai rien calculer honnêtement
mais je répète du
même sûrement moi je suis pas trop dans
l'eure
dans le truck malheureusement à la rate
ensuite être des solutions encore
quelle fut un coup de dé cape pour
commencer
je t'ai toujours un peu vite à je suis
pas date à la cadence
quand il fait ça je peux être faire g5
fou prend qu'avait lieu 4,6 mais bon
c'est quand même fou avec un pion de moi
a été un gros pions de moins et c'est
sûr qu'elle valait à capter des 5 g cac
et prend b4 tourbe est un jeu peut
reprendre g4 prendre ces 5 déjoué trois
pions pour la pièce où je peux laisser
prendre h5 et jouer les deux points mais
je sais pas tu peux voir un truc pareil
qui vient en a 2 avec le cavale je peux
faire à 5
un truc qui tombe je peux jouer à 5
et sur b5
j'arrive ici peut-être pas m'activer
suffisamment
qu'il prend là
je vais peut-être prendre et cif et bk
de fer qui est b3 qui est français un g5
et sortir le fou ici je veux faire ça
comme ça et s'ils bougent le cavalier
chevet g4
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir avec mon fou
dans je peux prendre effet refuge et 4
je crois bien je sais pas trop si je
suis moins bien ou pas à la sortie de
savez moi je n'ai pas perdu mon fou je
me suis bien battue est pas terrible
hein ce que je jouais mais au moins j'ai
trouvé deux cavaliers prend machin le g5
je pense que je me suis bien battu l'un
je me suis bien battu faire le fou
j'écarte kg sauver j'ai sauvé la pièce
ce qui est déjà pas mal
aucun ace développe je mette influents
des six
franchement je suis pas en grande forme
là
si qu au niveau des pions c'est juste
égalité matérielle cette mère dresser
galerie matériel 303,5 hockey
que ça fait sens de prendre les maîtres
lecavalier a eu quatre je vais empêcher
cavale et c5 faire une focale sur ce
gala ah j'ai oublié ça
c'est la presse
on joue à prendre une fois ici
je dois pouvoir jouer grand robe quand
même que tout reprend dégagé franges et
trois sur échec qui peut peut-être
penser look et les pions france est
bizarre ok et grand roque ses shows de
ses shows de night p5 ces cinq caisses
szostak cadence 5 plus de compte des
bons grands maîtres surtout que les
iraniens sont d'excellents envie de ça
mais plutôt content de la partie je
tiens milliard je connais pas la théorie
non adressé à moi de la prendre c'est
mon problème de pâques honnête mais sont
donc t'as pas la théorie avec les noirs
tu as un gros désavantage et je pense
que je m'en suis plutôt bien sorti
tactiquement maintenant on va voir
je crois faire une bonne partie je vous
sors un gros match les mecs en plus un
service si vous faites pas le tape
derrière
que j'ai envie de faire tour des six ans
soit et seul un [ __ ] il ya 1,7
non j'ai oublié à cet essai foutu jouer
trop vite ce qui à tour courage cet
échec il fallait faire ou à ses sept
comme voulait faire de base
ok il n'a pas vu
mais c'est un problème parce que je dois
à l'empêcher hockey du coup faut que je
prenne ici c'est juste que ce que je
voulais faire de bassa aurait pas du
tout marché du coup en gros je veux tout
reprend tout reprend pions prend roi ses
sept tours à j-6 f6 donc est là je peux
faire c'est 5 du coût ac 3b sept tours à
4 et j'ai peut-être fait roi à 8
il commence par ça que j'ai fait 3 b 8
pour roy à 7
je peux pas me permettre de laisser ce
dangereux criminels inception est
vraiment dangereux donc faut que je me
mette devant pour pas à laisser à 7
et maintenant je veux h 6 tours c8 pense
que je les dominants calcul mais ça
reste chaud dommage qu'ils aient ce
rajout de temples autres l'a5 plus déjà
je veux cinq buts deux en réalité dans
la vie j'ai toujours considéré que
qu'est la question c'est ce que je fais
tour ses huit jeu-là ce pion h et je
vous sais 4 après où est ce que je fais
h6 tourisme sitour e8 galfard h 10 quand
même
mais je suis quand même contente
protéger ça je vais pas laisser ça te
rend très couru vite tempo
et maintenant je veux tour c6 c4 en
avoir même cavale je peux vouloir
beaucoup de choses ok ça j'étais sur
kazim et c'est purement spéculatif
j'encaisse
et je vais tours 7 il va faire cavalier
à 6 non
je vais retour des 5 c'est plus
ambitieux parce que je tourcoing f5 sur
échec et je vais en caisse espion
gk retour 17
ces gens que c'est lui
je vais changer ça
je m'éloigne emma tour surtout après
il faut que je regagne un échec
je ramène le roi maintenant ici
on va faire un échec deux échecs
la rejouer ça
j'ai bloqué le pion
ok je peux faire des trois ce que j'ai
tour échec et je reviens
je crois que je reviens je bellion
ok comment bien gagner le chat a dit ça
sent la news est comme une meilleure
technique en finale que que beaucoup à
gaza ces chats
c'est très chiant
bon on va voir
c'est un problème
aïe poney
ça me force à comme ça pour pas perdre
sur le faux pas être moins bien sur le
champ
si on prend comme ça jusqu'à idée de il
joue sur les deux pions ça être 18h
barrette a eu tort ok je peux prendre
faire car il ya 3 promet d'être très
joli dribble est un peu différent de la
variante habituel donc j'ai peut-être
réussi à le dribbler
c'est elle même avec le foin f4
d'habitude dans le système de londres et
du coup moi j'ai mille fois angers 5 la
seule différence est que tu peux prendre
des phares 4 et du coup peut-être
connais pas très bien
corner dans la game jeu pas ce qui se
passe dans le match terne on est déjà
mené 43 51 hockey crise qui était 2e 5
cavale bouffe c4 puis on bouffe des
quatre on peut vous désister auquel je
tentais ça met sur les rails à 5 faire
fou de foot est un
ok il ya pranger lucky peu rodé mais je
veux juste faire tour g1 est fou des
reins est allé encaisser 5 et il peut
encore y faire 5 c'était sur foot est un
il va faire tout reprend à 3 vous prend
à 3 à froid trois chiens au kef 3,4 sur
échec c'est chiant c'est chiant de quoi
c'est chiant de rien du tout c'est
chiant de rien du tout je t'ai mis 2 0
je t'ai mis 2 0 et voilà les amis
comment comment comment on fait très mal
à l'iran là les amis on l'a fait mal je
n'avais pas vu vous prend 1,3 et je me
disais bien là c'est quoi ça ça commence
à voir flou côté iranien n'est pas plus
fort que moi les amis on et remonte à
2008 100 en plus ça va trois et demi sur
quatre contre dgm j'ai envie de dire je
fais mon match je fais mon match les
amis on va quand même perdre je suis un
peu d'air à ses rôles ou quoi servons
nous de faire son match et non pas vous
en vouloir mais bon si on avait les
forfaits
je regarde un peu là le classement est
rennes c'est fait on s'est fait prendre
là ils ont ils ont été peu trop joueur
là ils ont eu peur vous avez perdu et
l'eau manque d'expérience côté français
on s'est fait manger en milieu de
terrain s'est fait manger en milieu de
terrain
ouais bon c'est pas mal quand même
je suis de ça qui a fait deux nuls et la
turquie au rêve s'est fait manger 1
on s'est fait manger devant c'est
dommage les petits de 0 à caen même qui
faisait bien plaisir par crystal si peu
bon en valeur ajoutée petite mito est
d'accord ça à la taupe
crois tu ne dit pas tout est pas déjà ce
genre de match à ce que tout le monde
s'en fout en fait j'ai passé quand même
c'est pas ce que vous faites dans la vie
mais pour pour mes copains et j'aime
jouer aux échecs c'est travailler tu
vois je pense que vous vous chopez vous
chauffer pour faire pour faire des
heures sup si votre patron il vous
appelle le dimanche
il vous dit tiens de 19h à 21h30
il ya des dossiers à venir à venir
terminer au bureau thé chaud ça après
c'est un concept 1 mais je sais pas si
vous seriez chaud mais merci patron
paraissait sa merci de m'avoir rappelé
pour travailler quelques heures
supplémentaires non payées
je suis très heureux
il ya que 2 matches devaient y en a un
troisième mois je sais pas si je vais
jouer c'est du 10 + 2
je suis pas sûr disent + 2 pas une
cadence qui me fait kiffer perso on va
voir
j'ai quand même content de remonter les
2800 là sur une chaise comme mais c'est
vrai que si remettre une équipe de ouf
comme ça je me dis je rejouerai
peut-être la semaine la semaine
prochaine contre l'argentine ou quoi
c'est vrai que là ils ont quand même une
équipe de malade 1
approche penche franchement je trouve
qu'on s'est bien battu quand même on
était quand même loin d'être favoris et
je trouve qu'on fait un je trouve qu'on
fait un bon résultat
mon père mais pas tant que ça la crypte
heil a plus aucune rupture avec les
pions il va se faire bouffer h 2
il va tenter de jouer avec 1,4 mais
c'est foutu
si ce match n'est pas eu le temps de
faire à trois sinon ton courage 4 ça
offrait un fou et s'il vous prend b3
peut-être moi il ya peut-être un peu de
contre encore le permettent le cas
durant ces 4 c'est bien joué
vraiment ils sont forts ils sont forts
après
après tout gagnant n'a côté blanc singes
à 24 points d'écart ouais c'est un
massacre en faire plus de partie
pédagogique
enfin faire plus de partie pédagogique
ouais on manque
il nous manque cinq six joueurs à plus
de 2005 et et on pourrait on pourrait
faire un peu quelque chose quoi
un petit peu quelque chose
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont h 3 h 2 c'est
foutu salut et anne entre cristal en
chair et en os et alors il est beau
gosse le cristal est ce qu'il est beau
gosse c'est la question qu'on se pose
trop trop beau gosse ouais c'est genre
niveau de bogossitude les iraniens font
une sélection wesh possible aussi mais
bon nous pas l'esprit 1 c'est la
déception nada les amis on a perdu non
mais en vrai dans l'est sur les dans les
autres pays en fait il ya moins de il ya
moins de joueurs complètement amateur
qui suivent
il aurait dû tenter là c'est une erreur
qui l'a fait
peut-être peut-être trois b2c un piège
des sens ce que s'il bouge à temps vers
le haut il peut avoir envie à agen dame
est ici dame manqué toujours dames et
les reprendre la gipa j'aurais plutôt
fait ça comme ça perso c'est un mythe il
a dû sacrifier ray il va y sacrifier la
tour contre le pion et il va les envoyer
trois pions et je pensais plus simple
une petite fortune on s'en va ça va ça
va j'ai fait les points après petite
heure après on est plutôt pour plus pour
l'équipe que pour que pour les résultats
perso donc ouais petite déception en
déception de padt pas de pas être ne pas
être allé chercher la gagne mais on joue
des knicks était possible si on se
dépasser tout c'est tout on a quand même
fait un bon score
quand même fait un score un score assez
honnête donc c'est cool qui stream peut
épouser du dimanche soir n'ont prévu
comme ça donc il joue toutes les
semaines un la team france donc
n'hésitez pas à les aider moi je veux
voir le prochain match il ya vraiment
une grosse équipe en face je vais parler
pendant une heure si la personne qui
s'inscrit de leur côté je suis un vrai
peut-être vous filer un coup de main
je crois que pour s'organiser avec
l'équipe faut demander à adrian chan
mais je crois qu'ils sont sur le
discorde bitstream discorde un certain
kevin b qui a bien connu dans le milieu
bon je vais pas citer son nom voilà et
angel rapide mais du coup si j'ai bien
compris c'est lille a perdu et anne
contre 1 contre 1,2 me l'iranien iranien
en arménien ce matin
si j'ai bien compris
puis j'ai pu mal comprendre mais si j'ai
compris le sens de son sms
il a perdu
maintenant kevin de préfère rester dans
l'anonymat voilà non mais c'était sympa
ces matches je pense qu'on perd pas
après j'ai pas vu toutes les parties 1
on n'était pas si mal
maintenant je leur ai ramené à 2000 qui
avait tutoyé qui s'aiment qui affectera
de car on parle je suis un peu perdu
sébastien joueur havrais
ce match m'a donné un peu chaud là les
mecs je vais peut-être aller prendre la
température
si je me mets un peu à tous et et a
mouché jeu mettant sur la
non mais je pense pas que je le fasse un
match riche fini tard et ou non ça vient
trop tard c'est bien d'être avons dit
c'est vraiment la partie non il m'a pas
raconté étonne mais vu son sms j'ai
compris qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu
spécial
donc attendez stressé c'est mon
téléphone qui est qu'est ce qu'ils font
gens qui m'écrivent
la france ira jusqu'au bout je vous
transmets ma force quoi voilà ce que j
ai pas vraiment que je suis kiev et j'ai
du mal j'ai dû faire une quinzaine de
parties lancement j'ai envie de m'y
mettre
avez vous regardé songe aux échecs en
fait c'est fantastique
il te dira mais envoie le gars n'étaient
pas être du tout sans entrer dans les
détails on est mais je vous ai dit j'ai
déjà dit à simple quand il était chez
moi enfin c'est déjà parlé sur un autre
stream ou quoi via ces voies la fin
c'est comme ça on sent juste que tu as
certainement mais là c'est sur la chaîne
chaise comme je vais pas fut pas faire
du tfc ici hein mais bon je suis monté
aura tft quand même faut le savoir je
dirige presque jamais pour bien son
pseudo pleutre plus marrant cinéma
risquent de prendre le train merci à big
ben à none pour l'autriche prime merci
tonton
ouais non franchement je vais pas
participer
j'ai participé je suis là on va se
reprendre après fait le ça vous fait
faire des parties d'entraînement et tout
c'est sympa mais là je vais pas me
lancer sur un truc de 35 minutes pour
une nouvelle défaite à la écrite avance
ou pas on a toujours une petite chance
mais à ya pas assez de y'a pas assez
dangereux
je ne commence à tft j'adore dit eric
helmand est sympa tu as fait faut que je
réussisse à monter platines on m'a dit
couscous royal mais qu'il m'a fait des
prêts les et chaque humain en licence et
je suis musulman je m'amuse beaucoup
merci à toi c'est plus important tu
commandes maintenant je vais aller
passer un dimanche soir normal avec des
gens normaux non on a fait des bonds
franchement on a fait des beaux matchs
et mais qu'at on n'a pas à rougir un cas
pas de masque ni je viens de m'inscrire
mon club moi aussi bas c'est cool mais
c'est bien rock la boue
mais il fait chaud mais peut-être un
pull en cachemire aussi club de
ollioules ouais je sais pas faim ban a
fortiori je connais pas a fortiori
dimanche prochain si je suis là faut
vraiment qu'on se d'état par les
argentins vraiment fort qu'on va essayer
les chercher un hi eric morillo ouais
c'est cool je pense qu'il est bien mais
ils font des parties longues c'est le
club d'avoine m écoutent les argentins
je crois que c'est dimanche prochain à
19h forêt demandera adrian cham mais je
sais pas s'il adrienne cham
donc tu connais avoir de nom je connais
le lait d'avoine aussi le fameux les
qu'il ya un client d'avoine
ça ouais je connais si le bal d'avoine
très bien sûr bien sûr je t'aurais pas
gardons le cap ferret il faisait un peu
froid aujourd'hui j'ai mis ce truc là
mais a il fait un peu chaud là
maintenant bon les gars je vous laisser
jouer le match commence dans deux
minutes je remets le lien à une dernière
fois
ceux qui le souhaitent je vous remercie
encore d'avoir joué en ma compagnie ses
deux premiers matches j'espère qu'on
fera mieux la semaine prochaine on s'est
bien battu on a tout donné
c'était cool on s'est fait plaisir bref
qu'on se prépare mais après avec les
candidats et où si on commence à les
faire tous les dimanches on va commencer
à voir une grosse équipe les mecs ça va
être cool
sur ce bonne soirée à tous ciao ciao
amusez vous bien
mais surtout à bas